[Applause]
[Music]
so thank you very much indeed Peter for
that kind introduction and of course
it's also a great honor to be selected
by the Nobel Committee for chemistry and
the Royal Swedish Academy to to share
with Jacques and Yocum
this year's 2017 Nobel Prize in
Chemistry but I wanted to begin by
saying that the three of us are really
representatives of what's now become
quite closely knit and well organized
filled with a phenomenal growth rate so
I'd like to start by showing the first
slide which is from the first three
dimensional electron microscopy annual
Gordon conference that was organized in
1985 by the two people in the yellow
circles nigel Anwen and watchu and so
they had the idea this field was going
to grow and inaugurated this meeting
which is now held every year and I think
you can see in the red circles that
Jacques Yocum and I are clustered around
being as close as possible to Nigel and
wah but there are other people in in the
and this is about a hundred people who
are where the field was starting there's
a few more who weren't at the meeting
but I particularly wanted to point out
because the group of Bob Glaser Ken
Taylor and Ken downing they were doing
low-temperature
electron microscopy cryo microscopy
before those of us who are here today so
they were early adopters of that idea
and then because I'm the first speaker I
wanted to show also a kind of overview
of so that you know what is electron cry
microscopy which we call cry wee M for
short and it comes in many different
flavors because once you have a good
electron cry microscope you can put all
sorts of different specimens into it and
this slide sort of summarizes a variety
of the things that have been studied and
have been
quite informative so on the left is a
field of view showing amorphous ice with
ribosomes embedded in it this is single
particles without symmetry and this is
from work that you will hear more about
from yoke and Frank and this was their
state of play in roughly the year 2000
from a review that Tim Baker and I wrote
so single particles without symmetry
single particles with symmetry this is
hepatitis B virus caused from Bettina
bhaturas work in 1997 this was the first
structure that went below nanometer
below 10 angstrom resolution and then
the third panel is helical arrangements
of biomolecules so this is the thin
filaments in muscle decorated with
subunits of myosin from the work of Ron
Milliken the blue is actin the green is
tropomyosin and the different colors
pink orange and yellow are the different
domains of the myosin that's involved in
muscle contractility this is relatively
low-resolution all of these were fairly
low-resolution but on the right is the
2d crystals that I'll talk about at the
beginning of my own part of the talk
this was the second high resolution
structure determined by cryo a.m. by
Verner cool Brant and with collaboration
with fujiyoshi in Japan in in 1994 and
shows a 2d crystal at higher resolution
because the 2d crystals were easier to
start with which is how I'll start so
that is a range of specimens giving a
kind of overview the structures here are
about six times bigger magnification
than the images at the top but you can
see and it's this is so this is much
easier to understand and the
gravitational waves and the black hole
so you just take images of the molecules
you can see them and then in the
computer you calculate the structure so
you know anyone can do this kind of work
so then I want to jump forward and this
is this year's Gordon conference so this
is now 32 years later it's a it's a
bigger group
more highly selected and I've you see
some of the faces Bob Glaser and and
Yocum myself but I've outlined in yellow
some of the people who more recently
have made very important contributions
in terms of developing all the computer
programs that has make it so easy and so
popular amongst newcomers who don't know
so much about it so Fred Singh was one
of the original maximum maximum
likelihood sure share as an equal
Grigory F Marion van heel who'd worked
with Yocum at one point and and correct
so from Spain and then to other people
in the bill blue Bridget Carriker and
Helen Sabol who in the USA and in Europe
have been very important in running
courses and educating people although
they also did individual work in the
past so that gives you a little bit of
an overview of the community and how the
closely knit sort of brother and
sisterhood of cryo-em has adopted its
own sort of culture and identity and
that's very important and so we are only
the tip of the iceberg if you like in
this Cryer area and then to give you an
idea of where we are now this is the
growth in the deep positions of
high-resolution atomic coordinates in
the protein databank which traditionally
had only coordinates deposited from
x-ray crystallography and nuclear
magnetic resonance spectroscopy and you
see back in in the 1990s and so on there
were invisible numbers of structures but
in the last five years has been a great
growth and it looks like this year we
learned that with about 700 new
structures deposited in this protein
databank more maps and and and we then
have a we have the Gordon conferences
there's a 3d en mailing list which
didn't exist until 1995 started by Ross
Smith but when that first Gordon Corps
first started we were probably about a
hundred or 150 people now there are
3,000 people who subscribe to that
mailing list so that gives you an idea
of the field and the importance of the
community so now I just like to I'm
going to do three things in this talk so
tell you how I got
involved in being converted by meeting
Nigel and went from an x-ray
crystallographer to an electron
microscopy enthusiast and then how we
work together to get a low resolution
structure of a membrane protein back to
your dachshund then a high resolution
structure and then how our own efforts
switched from being electron
crystallography into single particle e/m
and which has been the methodology
that's made the method really popular so
going back now to about in my case 1971
or 72 I heard a talk by Walter stack
Elias in San Francisco this is the first
time he talked about it he had
discovered in a bacterium halo bacteria
these membrane areas they his creations
these are little two-dimensional
crystals one molecule thick and with
backing and support from Don Engelmann
and Tom Stites at Yale we phoned up
zucchinis and got some samples of these
bacteria grew them up and then purified
these membranes and each one of these is
a little single crystal maybe a hundred
molecules or two hundred across so 20 or
30,000 of these identical protein
molecules in this 2d crystal and my
original plan had been to dissolve them
in detergent make 3d crystals or analyze
the 2d pattern and this is an x-ray
powder pattern from
stacks pellets of those same membranes
that you saw in single sheets and so
there are lots of spots you can see they
go out this would be the one the first
spot second third and so on and this is
about seven angstrom resolution they're
all very strong but you can see them all
going out and you can index them right
oh right the way out to three or four
angstrom resolution so that showed that
these 2d crystals were really highly
ordered and very suitable for structural
analysis and at that point I had the
great good fortune to meet Nigel Unwin
who had been giving a talk about
electron microscopy using negative stain
but in that talk it was clear he
thinking about how the images would also
contain inside the stain the images of
the proteins that were being encased in
it so we work together for two or three
years doing on these little patches that
would be one of these crystals electron
diffraction and these spots are the
diffraction spots from the lattice of
molecules in the crystal and images that
could then be analyzed either in the
computer or by optical diffraction to
give you the amplitudes and phases of
the three components that describe the
distribution in the matter in the
crystals and when we we only saw the
spots and we had numbers we wrote them a
sheet of paper and then to our great
delight when we submitted these averages
and faces to the computer and then went
down to the big computer in Cambridge
University we got this map which was
surprisingly informative and very
beautiful we thought the plotter which
was the only accurate plotter in all of
Cambridge at the time had three color
pens the red green and the blue that
said the red green and the black and it
showed in projection three of these
protein molecules with big Peaks 10
angstroms apart and and we'd already
suspected from the x-ray pattern that
there were alpha helixes this is the
Pauling quarry alpha helix from the
model building that they did in the
1950s and which had been discovered in
myoglobin and hemoglobin but here we now
have these alpha helix YZ pointing
towards us in a top view of the
membranes so then we continued tilted
the specimens and went into 3d got these
3d maps that are plotted on sheets of
perspex with hand drawn the the computer
plotter couldn't do floating on per spec
sheet so these had to be hand drawn from
computer plots and then looking at it
sideways we built this balsa wood model
in 3d which showed that not only the
four after Gila C's that could be seen
and on in the projection but with slight
tilts there were seven transmembrane
helix seas and this was the first real
strong and hard knowledge about the
structure of membrane proteins 1975 we
were at that point stuck
in terms of knowing that the crystals
were better ordered but not knowing how
to to proceed and then we tried various
things but in the interim Hartmann
Mikkel who had been also working on
bhakti Robson managed to crystallize
another membrane protein so in the end
the first high-resolution membrane
structure was the reaction centers that
Heartland Michael and his colleagues
from Barton's read were given the
chemistry Nobel Prize in 1988 which was
before we managed to do any better with
this so then we went on and tried to go
from seven angstroms to a higher
resolution where you could see the
chemistry the amino acids in the side
chains and that needed a couple of
things it needed higher resolution
electron diffraction patterns and all
the work I've shown you up to now was
done with specimens at room temperature
where the water that normally surrounds
the the the protein that the membranes
had been replaced by a sugar solution by
glucose but now we had cold stages in
Cambridge that we could take electron
diffraction patterns on film initially
and this one was later with the
development of electronic detectors but
our microscopes in Cambridge were not
capable of doing high-resolution imaging
of cryo specimens and and what
encouraged us was this paper from watch
you the same person who chaired the very
first prime 3d M Gordon conference he
had worked with Fritz Sam Lynn in Berlin
who had a very high-performance
prototype microscope that had been made
by the siemens company liquid helium
lens a liquid helium stage and he took
pictures of this two-dimensional 3 it's
lightly thin 3d crystal of pro toxin a
structure we still don't know to this
day but he showed images of crystals
with diffraction spots from the
bridges that went beyond 4 angstroms
23.9 just the resolution that we were
looking for so this and the existence of
the electron diffraction patterns with
cryo convinced us that we should make a
major effort then to get into high
resolution electron Kryon microscopy
with the idea of determining the
structure of this membrane protein but
on in doing that we did try other things
for many years and so on this slide in
red is what worked and in these other
three panels are other ideas that we
tried so tom Seska David a guard and
Joyce Baldwin tried this was our idea to
bring the methods of x-ray
crystallography into electron
crystallography but they weren't they
just weren't powerful enough the heavy
atoms don't scatter as much in electrons
and so on this was the idea of using
heavy atom derivatives we found the
heavy atoms but the phasing power was
not enough we tried model building we
knew where the HeLa C's were so in
principle you could search for the
location wasn't perfect and we tried
molecular replacement with more than one
crystal form it worked slightly but
again not powerful enough what worked in
the end was to take images just like you
saw for Crowe toxin from watches work in
Berlin and then also we began actually
with a one-week trip to Jacques Dubois
Shay's lab who was an EMBL at that time
and he'll tell you about this later and
Zhang de Paul worked for a week on a
really very difficult to use microscope
I think which they dismantled after but
we did get one image the very first
high-resolution image which then gave us
further encouragement and then visiting
Burton's 1984-1985 following in watch
his footsteps we went to to Berlin
Fritz Emmaline Erich Becklund worked for
many years five or six years taking
images making the microscope better and
then in parallel
Bob Glaser who had been visiting us
persuaded Ken downing also to take
pictures so in the end we had
contributions from three different labs
trap and we also tried in Cambridge but
we never got image as good as these
these were all prototype
noncommercial not available and of
course after it worked we then tried to
put pressure on the microscope
manufacturers to develop the commercial
versions which means what we now use in
parallel with the practical problem of
getting really good high resolution
images there were a number of technical
things that I won't go into but
particularly finding out that beam tilt
was one of the critical problems that we
hadn't realized and I'll figure out a
way in tilted specimens to correct for
the different height the different D
focus but after doing that we ended up
with improved maps so eventually from
1975 to 1990 years worth of various
problems I don't think it costs nearly
so much as the gravity wave project but
we went from this is the same map I
showed you with the balsa wood model
seven angstrom resolution in 1975
slightly better by molecular replacement
these features turned out to be real
although we weren't sure at the time and
then the first 50 images gave us a map
with more better resolve features and
eventually with about 70 we got a map
where you can see key features sticking
out from the alpha helixes and at higher
magnification they looked like this and
when we then tried to interpret that map
using the amino acid sequence from of
chinny cough and caranas lab which by
then had been determined by biochemistry
we found that you could interpret the
map and see phenylalanine tyrosine
tryptophan and other tyrosine and then
the retinal the color of the membranes
they were purple we could see all of
these structures and built a complete
atomic model of the battery drops and
that was about 1990 and it was the first
high-resolution structure where you
could use electron microscopy to
determine the structures so then we went
on and did other work in the early 1990s
nickel grigoriev refined the structure
Sri Ram came we did lots of kinetic
strapping intermediates and so on but at
that time I also got involved in a
review for an x-ray microscope and ended
up writing a review comparing the
radiation damage from neutrons x-rays
and electrons
and I then became completely convinced
that the e/m method was definitely the
way to go and had an enormous untapped
potential so we switched our effort from
working on electron crystallography with
crystals you still have to make crystals
whether it's in 2d or 3d to working on
single particles and and trying to
assist the method in going from the
relatively low resolution to try to go
to a higher resolution and of course in
this respect and Jacques will tell you
about this in due course Jaques group at
the MBL had been exploring the behavior
of water when he froze it and they had a
variety of of gravity-driven or elastic
band driven freezing apparatuses and I
thought I'd just since I'm speaking
first I should give you a little outline
of it this is the the cryo am grid
preparation method that mark Adrien
Alistair McDowell who's here and Jacques
developed in the early 1980s the idea is
you take grids that have got holy carbon
films on it this says wholly carbon film
you you take them one at a time in a
pair of forceps you apply a drop of your
solution with your protein of choice or
you arrive in some or whatever you blot
it on a piece of filter paper and then
you plunge it one or two meters per
second into liquid ethane which was
allister's idea occasionally when we
were working on bacteria we also flashed
it with light but when you did that you
get images beautiful images where you
see the amorphous ice this was a
specimen that Richard param gave us
Peter Rosenthal made the specimen V
naught Kumar took this image quite
recently with the new detectors you can
see the particles you could see their
orientation it's clear without doing any
further computation that it's really
powerful and then this is the very first
hepatitis V virus core work that came
from Tony Grider's group done by Bettina
botcher and Nicolai kiselev had brought
from Riga in Latvia a specimen early on
in 1994 and using older microscopes not
such bright sources not very Korean they
got a first 30 angstrom resolution
cryo-em structure in 1994 and then we
bought a
a higher voltage field emission gun
brighter source microscope which Bettina
used with specimens that Sam Wynn had
made in Tony's computer program and they
got this then first structure from
single-party who work to go below 10
angstroms we called it sub nanometer
structure and of course now we're now
twenty years further on this is a recent
paper published from Hong Joos group at
UCLA higher voltage brighter microscope
much more stable but still all of these
are pictures taken on film and they got
a 3.5 angstrom resolution structure you
can see these are alpha helix a bundle
of four alpha helixes you can see the
side chains and so on so the microscopes
due to pressure from the academic
researchers but response by the
microscope countries produce much better
data so then the thing that's kicked the
field off in the last few years these
new detectors came in previously we were
using film there are three companies
that now make detectors they're now
better than this they're now up here
this would be a perfect detector at the
top using these detectors I'm going to
show you just two structures one of them
is beta galactosidase which I think was
the structure that Peter had in his
introductory slide this is a half a mega
Dalton structure it's the lack see the
very first operon discovered in the
early stages of understanding gene
expression and we had adopted this in
1997 when Sriram Subramanian and
Jacqueline mills were there learning and
deciding to get into cryo a.m. and this
was the first we didn't believe this
structure in 2005 low resolution this
was the first time we believed it this
was done on film and we hadn't by then
we had new analytical methods tilt pairs
and so on that proved that this was
correct but as soon as the new detectors
came in here we had higher resolution
and then with new programs such as rely
on from shore Charon the same data gave
us much higher resolution you could
resolve then the strands of the
polypeptide in the beta sheets and then
Sriram who had by then an independent
group at NIH worked much harder on this
turn the magnet
collected better data and has now a 2.2
angstrom data structure and I've
believed now this is now better than 2
angstroms from subsequent work and then
a second one I wanted to show you is
mitochondrial complex one which again
Nikko grigoriev had worked on back in
the late 1990s with film and got to
about 20 angstrom resolution recently
Judy Hearst from another MRC unit
brought a sample across and Vinoth Kumar
started to take it this is one of his
pictures this is a one mega Dalton
complex with 45 different proteins in it
and it has no symmetry you can see it
has also two different views when you
record images and process them you get a
map like this in 3d contour at one level
or at a higher level and you can see the
8 iron sulfur complexes where electrons
are fed in from nadh come down into the
membrane into quinone and involved in
proton transport and then in the
membrane there are 76 transmembrane
helix C's this is about 5 angstrom
resolution so you rather similar to the
bacteria adopts an early map at room
temperature so you can see the general
structure of the of the protein but not
the detailed chemistry for which you
need higher resolution and then at a at
a lower contour a level still you see
the band of lipid and detergent that
sounds surrounds this membrane and the
protein but V North JPEG juhu had
prepared the protein in judy hers group
went on and improved it until they
eventually got a model with all 45
polypeptides identified and largely
built although there were some poly
alanine giving you a complete atomic
model for the structure and in blue in
the background are the core subunits
that a bacterial homologue of this
mitochondrial membrane protein involved
in proton transport coupling to
oxidative phosphorylation the blue is a
bacterial homologue that leo Saturn ops
group had determined earlier by x-ray
crystallography so that's a kind of
complete summary from
staged bacterial dobson to higher
resolution and then switching the the
approach if cry we am into the single
particle area I just want to finish that
with one slide and this is from recent
work that in the last year Chris Russo
and I have been doing and Chris's is in
the audience here and the idea is where
are we now
so we are now and so what this is this
tells you the amount of information in
images that you get with the new
microscopes and the new detectors and
this is the exposure that you're giving
it five electrons per square angstrom
then 10 and 15 and radiation damage
eventually kills the structure you're
turning it into a cinder a carbon
carbonaceous fragment of what was once a
beautiful protein so this is what we
what we observe when we analyze the data
but what we know we ought to observe if
all the remaining problems that exist
which are not nearly so profound as the
problems in getting gravitational waves
to go forward the red is where we're
hoping to be and then there are a number
of factors that explain we think why we
don't do as well as we should in theory
and the idea now for the next year or
two is to try to address all of these
problems but the main one being in this
blue area is beam induced specimen
motion from the radiation damage or from
releasing stresses that are is result
with the freezing in the first place and
then when we do that we think you'll be
able to do all the things I showed you
lots more
more than a thousand structures per year
and so on and it'll be less work and
more high-resolution as on so with that
I wanted to finish by saying that of
course quite a number of people have
been involved and I've worked with them
personally but the main one at the
beginning which which basically
converted me from an x-ray
crystallographer to an electron
microscopist and I think there was a
slight action and reaction because after
we had worked together on bacterial ops
and Nigel also changed still doing
electron microscopy but doing it on
membrane proteins as well so it was a an
important branching of our potential
career paths for both
of us and then we had this 15-year gap
where we had to work on a lot of
different methods and in Cambridge
Joyce Baldwin Tom Seska and David a
guard were the ones who were pushing it
but Bob Glazer and Ken downing were
important in taking pictures but
particularly Fritz and semolina and Eric
worked very hard for many years and then
we had this one week with with Jacques
and Jean the Paul in the early stages
that so that was the high resolution
group and then recently we've been
involved in a lot of the attempts to
improve the methodology through detector
development and microscope technical
developments and these are the people
huazi Gregg and Xiao Jie who is here
from Cambridge and the two people from
Rutherford Appleton science technology
facility Carson near Oxford who have
spent 15 years or so developing one of
the three types of detector that you can
now buy from the market and then more
recently when we switched into single
particle work I mentioned most of these
not in John Rubinstein who on one of the
different type of ATPase rotary motor
and Peter Rosenthal who prepared one of
the specimens that I showed you before
and then the early the most recent work
in all of the biological structures like
complex one came from V North Kumar who
is now just opened a new cry and
facility in Bangalore in India and then
finally in the last year Chris ruse and
I have been trying to address and solve
the remaining problems for the future
and then I should just finish by saying
that most of the work obviously the
people from other labs were funded by
other agencies but most of this was
funded by the Medical Research Council
which has always had since the time of
brutes and Kendrew a clear mandate to do
long term support for projects that take
longer than typical projects take so
with that thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]